let's talk about prescriptions
prescriptions are how-to's
they are
hacks and they are
techniques and methods various
methodologies to get somewhere when you
talk about something from the standpoint
of a mechanical behavior
turning on a computer riding a bicycle
prescriptions are
useful the problem is that whenever you
venture into the realm of art in any
form be it in business or sports or
even in the setting of
finding peace in your life or freedom or
arriving at
enlightenment or all of these so-called
spiritual pursuits
those things cannot be prescriptionized
if you attempt to prescriptionize them
what happens is the prescription becomes
the new god
you begin to
try to live up to the prescription
in the beginning
you had a place to go i want to go to x
then you introduce an intermediary the
prescription this is how you get to x
then what will happen is that your mind
will begin to focus upon the
intermediary and it will enter into a
deal which it never signed up for
that deal is that for the rest of your
life
you will attempt to satisfy the
intermediary
in all domains you have many people who
do great things
the buddha attained enlightenment you
have
michael jordan and tiger woods doing
amazing things in golf and
elon musk and various individuals who do
great things in business even yourself
if you take what those people did and
you write a book and said that these
people did x
if you follow that
you will not become them you will not
i've found business biographies to be
useless for building a great business
they're good for inspiration i can read
steve jobs bio and be inspired but i
can't be steve jobs and if i want to be
amazing at something then i have to find
my own way there for mechanical things
how to's work but when you're trying to
operate at the top of a field or when
you're trying to do something creative
how to's don't work beyond the most
extreme basics when you're first
starting something it is actually a
mechanical endeavor you're just figuring
out how to drive a car but when you're
trying to figure out how to race around
a track faster than anyone else
then all coaches and techniques and
prescriptions have to fall by the
wayside and you are at the edge of the
art
that's correct now the problem is
conditioning
when there's only when one loudspeaker
in a person's ear for his entire life
then that is his norm and that is the
only language that he knows
that paradigm of how to
is so embedded inside the culture it is
so deeply embedded inside the cortex of
the human brain that the idea of
omitting it or the idea of even
challenging its existence
is completely off the wall
it is so
otherworldly and antithetical
that it takes years to even get to the
point where
the idea of prescriptions being a
impediment
to whatever you seek
begins to dawn
people consider you to be
a spiritual guy on twitter and in my
understanding you're not like that at
all spirituality is a pointless word
it's about utility is something useful
does it get you where you want to go
you're always talking about extreme
performance and that's why your brand is
a performance it's a seeking performance
essentially and seeking the truth that
gets you to the highest performance in
all things whether it's business or
sports or peace of mind this drive
towards utility reality truth
performance
they somehow wander into spirituality
people interpret them in spiritual ways
but it feels like spirituality is so
cluttered with nonsense that it gets
lost
your model makes sense if one realizes
that it's designed to go after extreme
performance if you want to be the best
in the world at anything you cannot
follow prescription if you want to be
okay at it then sure you can follow
prescription if you want to learn how to
lose a pound a month and get in decent
shape then you can follow a calorie
counting worksheet but if you want to be
a shredded bodybuilder or an olympic
athlete you're not going to get there
through how-to's you're going to have to
create and forge your own path that is
unique to you
would that be a good way of putting it
well what i will add to that is that
one does not have to want to become
the greatest in the world
if you look at the lives of human beings
there is intense struggle the guy who
works three jobs doesn't want to work
three jobs he may not want to become
tiger woods but he wants to be beyond
being forced to work three jobs
what keeps him working three jobs is
prescriptions
the futility of prescriptions
does not just
harm one who wants to become world class
it gravely harms the one who simply
doesn't want to struggle the way i think
about it in the business world is that
hard work has very little to do with
effectiveness
the grocery store owner or the person
working at a restaurant might work 60 80
hours a week and that might be all elon
musk is working but elon's making a lot
more money because of his specific
knowledge knowledge that cannot be
taught but can be learned on the job if
you have a strong enough desire because
elon is doing the right things he is far
more effective in earning power and the
right things at least in business can't
be taught because it's a moving target
it can only give very vague principles
that inspire people to head in the right
direction but i can't teach you how to
make money or trade the stock market
it's like when people ask you for stock
tips
no one who's any good at stock trading
gives actionable investment advice in a
public forum because all the details are
too hard to convey i can always tell
people who ask for stock tips they're
not really serious about investing
people who ask for book recommendations
aren't really serious about reading
people who ask what business should i
build aren't really serious about
entrepreneurship
people who say what career path should i
take they're not really serious about
their career when someone's asking for a
how-to and anything they aren't actually
that serious about it if they were truly
serious about it they would figure it
out but then that leaves the paradoxical
question well how do i figure it out
take the person who quote made it and
became world class in whatever he did
if he went back and retraced his steps
and did everything again
the same way
but this time he did it by mimicking
himself he would fail
even he wouldn't be able to do it
what has to be understood
is that where greatness comes from
it's a very murky affair
it is non-linear
it is unpredictable
perhaps nature and the universe set it
up this way
that
you have to jump in
and once you jump in the soup
and you're being bombarded through all
sides and you live in confusion
and you have no idea which way is up
if the obsession is there
then what happens is through some
messy process
you find a way you see light at the end
of the tunnel you forge a path through
the jungle
that was not done according to a how you
were flailing the entire time so there
was no how to flail
when you come out through the tunnel and
someone asks you how you did it you have
no idea
the thing that's almost laughable is
when you ask a great athlete can you
show me how you did that they won't come
out and say i have no idea
they will provide you with some
semblance of an answer which is a
non-answer and what they will do is
because there's a gun point to their
head and their backs against a wall
they will create the highlights
when the human being who watches that
follows the highlights he misses and the
reason that he misses is because it's
all the small things
i can't watch roger federer play tennis
and swing the rocket the same way
nor will any description from him on how
to swing the rocket get me to swing it
the right way then we go to intellectual
efforts we start asking warren buffett
why he invests in a company and there he
can try and create a mental construct as
to how he thinks and how he invests in
the company but there are just as many
details to warren buffett's activities
when he decides what to invest in and
how he lives his life and how he thinks
as there are to roger federer's body
running around a tennis court hitting a
ball
the details are not transmissible
they're not copyable you can be inspired
to try it yourself but without that
sincerity that obsession you won't get
there
not only are the details not
transmissible the details are not even
knowable
ah so warren and roger don't even know
it themselves absolutely not no great
artist knows the things that you do
greatest are the things that you know
not how you do them i would argue that
you're not even there when you do them
you're not consciously thinking about it
i find that when i'm speaking i do best
when i'm not thinking about what i'm
going to say and i don't even hear what
i'm going to say until it comes out of
my mouth
there's this idea in union psychology
called the circumambulation and jung had
this idea that
you had a potential future self which
would be
in potential everything that you could
be and that it manifests itself moment
to moment in your present life by making
you interested in things
and the things that you're interested in
are the things that would guide you
along the path that would lead you to
maximal development
now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a
or a mystical idea even but
but it's not it's it's not it's a really
profoundly biological idea the idea is
something like well
you're set up so that you're
automatically interested in those things
that would
fully expand you as a well-adapted
creature well like
there's nothing radical about that idea
how well what else could possibly be the
case unless there's something
fundamentally flawed about you that is
what the situation would be it's kind of
interesting to think about how that
would be manifest moment to moment but
the idea is something like well your
interest is captured by those things
that lead you down
the path of development
well that better be the case okay so
that's fine and so there's some utility
in pursuing those things that you're
interested in that's the call to
adventure let's say
so and the call to adventure takes you
all sorts of places now the problem with
the call to adventure is like what the
hell do you know
you might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent
and often it's the case that when
new parts of people manifest themselves
and grip their interest say they do it
very badly and shoddily
and so you stumble around like an idiot
when you try to do something new that's
why the fool is the precursor to the
savior from the from the symbolic
perspectives because you have to be a
fool before you can be a master and if
you're not willing to be a fool then you
can't be a master so
so you're gonna it's an error
error ridden process and that's also
laid out in the old testament stories
because the first thing that happens to
all these patriarchal figures when
god kicks them out of their father's
house when they're like 84 is that they
they run into all sorts of trouble and
some of it's social and some of it's
natural some of it's a consequence of
their own moral inadequacy
so they're fools and but but the thing
that's so interesting is that despite
the fact that they're fools they're
still supposed to go on the adventure
and that they're capable of learning
enough as a consequence of moving
forward on the adventure so that they
straighten themselves out across time
and so it's something like this this
circumambulation that jung talked about
was this
continual will return to this this
continual circling in some sense of who
you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like
you're circling yourself and getting
closer to yourself as you move across
time that's the circumambulation now you
remember that for a second we'll go back
to it okay so imagine that something
glimmers before you it's an interest
that's dawning and you decide well first
of all you're paralyzed you think well
how do i know if i should pursue that
it's probably a stupid idea and the
proper response to that is you're right
it probably is a stupid idea because
almost all ideas are stupid
and so the the probability that as you
move forward on your adventure that
you're going to get it right the first
time is zero it's just not going to
happen and so then you might think well
maybe i'll just wait around until i get
the right idea and which people do right
so they're like 40 year old 13 year olds
which is not a good idea so they wait
around until it's waiting for godot
until they finally got it right but the
problem is you're too stupid to know
when you've got it right so waiting
around isn't going to help because even
if it the perfect opportunity manifested
itself to you in your incomplete form
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero
you might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere highly likely highly likely so
so you have there's
nietzsche called that a will to
stupidity which i really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it
you know it's it's you have to take it
into account fundamentally and work with
it and so
and so you can take these tentative
steps on your
pathway to destiny and you can assume
that you're going to do it badly and
that's really useful because you don't
have to beat yourself up it's pretty
easy to do it badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all and
that's the continual message that echoes
through these historical stories in
genesis it's like these are flawed
people
they they should have got the hell out
of their house way before they did um
and they go out and they stumble around
in tyranny and famine and self-betrayal
and
and
violence and but it's a hell of a lot
better than just rotting away at home
and that's the that's great so that's
good and so why is that well okay so you
you start your path and you think that
you're heading you know towards your
star
and so you go in that direction and
then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were
it's it's going to reveal itself with
more accuracy to you and so then you
have to take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
i mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than
you would be if you just stayed where
you were waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot
continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn
what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then
that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing
so it's okay so it's like this
now what's cool about it though i think
is that as you progress the
degree of overshooting starts to decline
right and that we know that there's
nothing hypothetical about that as you
learn a new skill like even to play play
a song on the piano for example you
overshoot madly you're making all sorts
of mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes
they they disappear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you